coluche candidat à l'élection
présidentielle monsieur coluche devrait
peut-être dire aujourd'hui qu'ils
avaient hier organisé une conférence de
presse comme tout le monde on pourrait
dire pour présenter cette candidature il
se retrouve aujourd'hui face à daniel
grandclément est l'invité du crible
d'antenne 2 c'est à vous alors est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous prenez au sérieux
ah ben c'est d'abord c'est surtout vous
qui prenez ça au sérieux puisque vous
m'invitez d'ailleurs je vous en remercie
mais effectivement martinez expliqué
oui je sais c'est l'endroit où vous
parlez vite pour qu'on n'ait pas le
temps de parler mais je vais m'habituer
parce que je les ai déjà vu l'émission
ma candidature est très sérieuse dans la
mesure où je fais plus de chances
d'avoir des voix que les autres
candidats qui se présentent quoi tout
simplement il ya plus de gens qui sont
censés adhéré à mon programme
enfin à mon cahier de charges et de
revendications c'est que les a c'est
quoi votre cahier de répartition pia
plus il ya peu près 14 %
d'abstentionnistes en france si on
compte les gens qui s'inscrivent pas or
au dernier sondage par exemple michel
debré l'aurait 8%
donc il est quand même très très loin
derrière très festive et sa très facile
à la limite avec quel candidat peut
réclamer les mêmes voies que vous oui
d'accord mais personne ne le fait c'est
ça le problème c'est que justement les
petits fours qui je me présente
il n'existe pas en politique c'est à
dire tout le monde les prendre pour rien
quoi et simplement ce que je leur
propose c'est de renvoyer le compliment
hommes politiques femme est montré
qu'ils sont nombreux qui existe deux
manières a renvoyé les compliments c'est
vous qui valaient rien en fait voilà
lorsqu'il ce qui peut apparaître comme
comme finalement assez amusant dans
votre candidature c'est un personnage
amusant
est ce que ça peut pas être un petit peu
dangereux pour les institutions c'est un
grand boum et tout simplement est ce que
vous attendez vous faut 500 signatures
pour que vous fassiez campagne
normalement si à la suite de votre
candidature
zeebo finalement faut plus des rigolos
comme coluche donc il faudra cinq mille
signatures est-ce que vous pensez que
j'aurais gagné ou finalement nous aurait
perdu c'est déjà ce qu'ils ont faim
parce qu'avant il fallait sans signature
et maintenant il en faut 500 et d'autre
part aujourd'hui il ya trente et un
candidat je crois oui 1 dont cinq sont
connus en fait
enfin il y en a trois qui sont pas
déclarés mais qui sont quand même très
très connu et il ya moins d'autres oui
il ya marie france garaud mais enfin
gare au gorille long elle a fait deux
jours et puis on en parle plus donc on
s'en fout et donc qu'est ce qui se passe
dans le truc politique en fait la gauche
avait une chance de gagner quand elle
était uni mail
plus donc elle n'a aucune chance de
gagner donc on est on est devant une
mascarade politique mais pas répandue si
effectivement je fais que résonnent
candidature si votre candidature a pour
principal résultat d'augmenter encore la
barre pour pour que les gens puissent se
présenter
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
c'est un risque et ce dans les cailloux
perdre parce que vous croyez que les
gens qui gouvernent donc la répression
comme moyen d'expression
eh bien vous avez raison c'est bien sûr
contre quoi je lutte justement je suis
pas d'accord qu'ils emmerdent avec des
lois antidémocratiques alors que il
clame partout qu'on est dans une
démocratie
quel a été le candidat le plus ennuyé de
lire ce que dit la presse de votre
candidature de savoir que vous êtes
candidat aujourd'hui à votre avis je ne
crois pas que quelqu'un qui sont ennuyés
s'agit brice lalonde peut être content
pourquoi je me sens voulu par les ong
écologistes
je prends les voix des abstentionnistes
personne ne les a jamais eu
moi je fais acte de civisme pour ces
gens là c'est à dire que les mecs que je
réclame à qui réclament de vote est bon
mais n'ont jamais voté comme moi
d'ailleurs
mais moi j'ai voté une fois quand j'ai
eu ma carte parce que je voulais savoir
si c'était utile et je me suis aperçu
que j'avais voté pour rien il ya des
mecs qui ont voté pendant 30 ans pour
rien il ya des gens qui ont voté à
gauche alors que la gauche a jamais
réussi à s'entendre parce qu'ils ont
fait passer leurs intérêts personnels
avant les intérêts de la france donc et
des français et puis ce qu'ont voté à
droite
ils ont bien vu que c'était pour rien
puisque le ministre a encore de dire
qu'on manquait pas de pétrole alors que
l'iran avec qui on est un allié dans
cette affaire l'a fait des restrictions
elles chez elle si un jour vous fait un
discours devant mille personnes et tout
à coup deux mille personnes se mettent à
applaudir sans rire mais vous riez
d'entrées payantes j'en fais plus que ça
aurait été si personne ne rit est ce que
vous n'avez pas changé d'attitude est ce
que ça va vous faire quelque chose de
voir mille type qui vous applaudissent
sans rire qui croit ce que vous dites ce
que vous prenez une responsabilité les
gens vont investir quelque chose en vous
mais les gens ils savent très bien que
toutes façons c'est une
c'est une plaisanterie puisque je me
présente au premier tour ce que je veux
simplement c'est que les mecs guînes
wren par les sages du tout sur le ton de
la plaisanterie il a pas du tout mais
oui mais parce que c'est cette c2 fait
que c'est pas une plaisanterie mais vous
aller t'entraîner obligatoirement à ce
que ce ne soit plus une plaisanterie
c'est grâce à vous que ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie si les journaux
on n'avait pas parlé autant de ma
conférence de presse d'hier et que vous
m'aidiez pas invité pour m'expliquer sur
ce sujet c'était pas sérieux c'est vous
qui rendent l affaire sérieuse et je
vous remercie encore une fois la messe
la vie mais cela dit elle est très
sérieuse parce qu'il ya effectivement
tout un tas de mecs qui sont français et
qui sont pas concernés par la politique
la politique prend pour vraiment zéro
que les équipes qui existent premier
point du programme c'est quoi la
première chose que vous n'y a pas de
programme c'est la première indication
en bas la première revendication c'est
tout c'est ce que les téléspectateurs ce
que les les mecs qui vont voter pour moi
ont commis des inouk à m'écrire en
disant nous dans notre pays par un parce
que chacun ses problèmes
le nord de la france à ces problèmes le
sud de la france à ces problèmes le
centre de la france à ces problèmes
manufrance je vous le fais pas dire
donc tout le monde a des problèmes qui
sont différents essais mais clan des
revendications et personnes sont
occupées
personne personne personne il y en a qui
font des promesses d'autres qui donne
des espoirs et puis à la fin du compte
on n'a rien on n'a rien rien je vous
remercie
eh ben je vous en prie
[Musique]